Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to Therapeutic Advances
in Antibody Drug Conjugates. This is one of the clinical
trials plenary sessions,
and
we are so happy to see that you joined us today.
As you know, antibody drug conjugates really
changed the shape of oncology, and they
moved so quickly from concepts
into the clinic. And today's session will
highlight four early clinical trials
with antibody drug conjugates, with new targets,
new payloads, with new combination strategies.
And after each presentation, we will
have a discussant who will help us interpret the
results and put it in the clinical context.
I am Cathy Dumbrava from MD Anderson, and with Dr.
Manuel Hidalgo from NYU, we are honored to be
moderating the session today. So let's get started with
our first presenter, Dr. Elizabeth Lee from
Dana-Farber Cancer Institute. Dr. Lee.
Good afternoon, everyone. On behalf of my co-authors, it is my
pleasure to present CTEP Trial Number 10355,
a Phase 1 trial of DS-8201A and olaparib
in HER2-expressing malignancies, results from dose escalation.
These are my disclosures. This was an investigator-initiated
study funded by the National Cancer Institute, Cancer Therapeutics
Evaluation Program, and conducted through the Experimental
Therapeutics Clinical Trials Network.
Topoisomerase 1 inhibitors trap topoisomerase 1
during DNA cleavage, generating topoisomerase DNA
cleavage complexes, also referred to as TOP1 cleavage
complexes.
The collision of replication forks and transcription complexes
with TOP1 cleavage complexes generate irreversible
cleavage complexes as cleaved DNA templates become
misaligned. Subsequently, there's the generation of
double-stranded DNA breaks.
The repair of these cleavage complexes relies in part on PARP,
which promotes replication fork reversal to prevent collisions,
and via PARylation recruits TDP1 to
excise these cleavage complexes.
Therefore, PARP inhibition potentiates the DNA-damaging
effects of TOP1 inhibition.
Of note, synergy between PARP inhibitors and TOP1 inhibitors
occurs due to PARP catalytic inhibition and is independent
of PARP trapping ability.
Multiple lines of pre-clinical evidence supports PARP inhibitor
potentiation of TOP1 inhibitor-induced
cytotoxicity.
In clinical studies, however, substantial rates of hematologic
toxicity, even when using a weak PARP trapper such as
veliparib, offset by low rates of clinical activity,
have limited combinations of PARP inhibitors with a classical
TOP1 inhibiting chemotherapy.
Therefore, we hypothesized that targeted delivery of a TOP1
inhibitor via an antibody drug conjugate may reduce
systemic toxicity and improve anti-tumor
efficacy.
We sought to evaluate this using DS-8201A, more
commonly known as trastuzumab deruxtecan or T-DXd,
which is a HER2-targeting ADC carrying a potent
exatecan derivative TOP1 inhibiting payload with a
drug antibody ratio of approximately eight.
At the time of trial initiation, DS-8201A was
only indicated for use in select breast and gastroesophageal
cancers.
We sought to combine DS-8201A with olaparib, a PARP
inhibitor which was indicated only for select ovarian, breast,
pancreatic, and prostate cancers at the time of study start.
We sequentially explored three dosing schedules of
olaparib with DS-8201A in three modules in dose
escalation. This illustration depicts the rationale
for gapped schedule olaparib dosing studied in two of the dose
escalation modules.
The rationale here is that after administration of a TOP1
inhibitor, TOP1 cleavage complexes remain loaded in
tumor cells, as depicted in the green areas under the curve,
while they are cleared from normal tissues, as depicted in the red areas under the
curve.
Therefore, administration of a PARP inhibitor a few days after a
TOP1 inhibitor may maximize tumor DNA damage
while mitigating effects in normal tissues.
However, as the optimal timing of PARP inhibition after TOP1
inhibition is not yet known, we explored differing schedules
in modules two and three.
In this Phase 1 study, we began enrollment in module one,
evaluating continuously dosed olaparib given days one through
21 of each 21-day cycle of treatment.
We subsequently explored gap schedule olaparib in module two, where
it was dosed days eight through 14,
and in module three, where olaparib was given days three through nine.
We enrolled adult patients with HER2-positive advanced solid
tumors, defined as those with HER2 IHC expression of
one plus or greater, or ERBB2 amplification.
Measurable disease per resist was requiredAt least one
prior line of cytotoxic chemotherapy was required, though there
was no upper limit on the total number of previous therapies.
Prior PARP inhibitor use was allowed.
The primary objectives of this study were to evaluate the safety and
tolerability of combined DS-8201A and olaparib
and to define and select the recommended Phase 2 dose.
Secondary objectives included the evaluation of clinical activity of
this combination as measured by the objective response rate,
clinical benefit rate, duration of response, and progression-free
survival.
In dose escalation, 28 patients received study therapy.
All were female with a median age of 64 years and had
either endometrial cancer or ovarian cancer.
These patients were heavily pre-treated, having received a median of
3.5 prior lines of therapy and a range of one to 10
prior lines.
Over 40% of patients had previously received PARP inhibitors.
The majority of patients had a platinum-free interval of less than six
months at the time of study entry.
43% of patients had endometrial cancer and
57% had ovarian cancer.
They were predominantly high-grade histologic subtypes, including
uterine serous carcinoma and high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma.
HER2 expression was required for eligibility, and local HER2
testing results showed that the majority of patients had an expression of
2+.
Within this group of 2+ expressers was one patient who was concurrently
reported as ERBB2 amplified and one patient for
whom local testing had an ambivalent score of
1+/2+.
The majority of patients had wild-type BRCA by local germline
and somatic testing.
In Module 1, we evaluated continuously dosed olaparib in
a 3+3 dose escalation design.
Patients were enrolled beginning at dose level one, in which
DS-8201A was dosed at 4.4 milligrams per
kilogram with olaparib 100 milligrams twice daily given
days one through 21.
Only one DLT was observed during the six-week DLT period,
and escalation to dose level two was allowed.
Here, DS-8201A was increased to 5.4 milligrams per
kilogram while olaparib remained at 100 milligrams days one through
21.
Enrollment halted at this dose level due to three patients experiencing
DLTs.
All DLTs were hematologic in nature.
Given this, Module 1 was declared infeasible and further enrollment to this
module was halted.
We subsequently evaluated seven days of gap schedule olaparib in
Module 2, again via a 3+3 dose escalation
design.
At dose level one, we evaluated DS-8201A
5.4 milligrams per kilogram with olaparib 100
milligrams twice daily, now given days eight through 14.
At this dose level, no DLTs were observed, allowing escalation to
dose level two, where olaparib was increased to 200
milligrams twice daily. And again, no DLTs were observed.
Escalation to the highest planned dose level was achieved, where olaparib was
increased again to 300 milligrams twice daily, days eight through 14.
Only one DLT was observed, and overall, Module 2 was
declared feasible.
We sought to investigate alternative timing of gap schedule olaparib in
Module 3. This module was designed as a single-dose level
cohort where DS-8201A was given at
5.4 milligrams per kilogram and olaparib at 300
milligrams twice daily, now given days three through nine.
Two patients experienced DLTs, halting further enrollment to this
module, which was declared infeasible.
Ultimately, the Module 2 regimen was selected as the recommended Phase 2
dose. DS-8201A 5.4 milligrams per
kilogram given once every three weeks with olaparib 300
milligrams twice daily given days eight through 14 was
selected for further investigation in the ongoing dose expansion
cohort.
Treatment-related adverse events were attenuated with gap schedule
olaparib compared to continuously dosed olaparib.
As shown here, treatment-related AEs were primarily hematologic
with low-grade gastrointestinal toxicities consistent with the
expected safety profile of both agents.
Of note, hematologic AEs were markedly attenuated in
Module 2 with gap schedule olaparib compared to Module 1.
As seen here, reduced frequencies of Grade 3 and Grade 4
neutropenia, anemia, and thrombocytopenia was
observed with gap schedule olaparib.
Pneumonitis was observed in patients enrolled to this study.
This was in keeping and consistent with the expected safety profile of these
agents and real-world reports.
All pneumonitis events were low grade and occurred across dosing
schedules, tumor types, and levels of HER2 expression.
The majority of events occurred in later treatment cycles,
and none occurred during the six-week DLT period.
As shown in this waterfall plot, deep tumor reductions were seen with
combined DS-8201A and olaparib. There was
encouraging evidence of anti-tumor efficacy with an objective
response rate of 54%
and a confirmed ORR of 46%. This includes a
confirmed complete response and 12 confirmed partial
responses.The confirmed clinical benefit rate was
67%, and the median duration of response was
11.2 months.
Responses were observed in both endometrial and ovarian cancer patients
across levels of HER2 expression and in patients who had
previously received PARP inhibitors and anti-HER2 agents.
As shown in the swimmer plot, durable disease control was also seen with
DS-8201A and olaparib.
This was seen across modules with a median duration of treatment of
36.1 weeks.
With a median follow-up of 8.4 months, 19 patients
were alive and progression-free at six months.
The six-month PFS was estimated at 88.2%
and the median progression-free survival was estimated at 15.2
months.
Clinical activity of combined DS-8201A and olaparib
was observed even in HER2 low settings.
For example, a confirmed partial response was observed in a patient with
HER2 IHC 1+ primary platinum-refractory clear
cell ovarian carcinoma, a subtype of ovarian cancer
historically considered to be chemotherapy-resistant.
This patient was heavily pretreated, having received carboplatin and
paclitaxel, palbociclib/gadadoliseib,
ipilimumab, nivolumab, and gemcitabine.
As shown here, there was marked reduction in size of a large omental
mass.
Similarly, a confirmed partial response was also seen in a patient with
HER2 IHC 1+ primary platinum-resistant
high-grade serous ovarian carcinoma.
This patient was also heavily pretreated and had PARP inhibitor-resistant
disease. As shown here, there was substantial shrinkage in the
peritoneal mass.
In conclusion, gapped schedule olaparib with
DS-8201A demonstrated an acceptable safety
profile.
Pneumonitis events were observed but were all low grade in seven patients.
DS-8201A 5.4 milligrams per kilogram given once
every three weeks, with olaparib 300 milligrams twice daily
given days eight through 14, was selected as the recommended Phase II
dose.
There was evidence of clinical activity across dose escalation modules,
tumor types, and levels of HER2 expression, including
those with HER2 IHC 1+ expression.
Fifty-four percent of patients demonstrated an objective response with a
confirmed ORR of 46%.
Nineteen patients were alive and progression-free at six months,
and the six-month PFS was estimated at 88.2%.
The median PFS was estimated at 15.2 months.
Based on these results from dose escalation, enrollment is ongoing
in a HER2 IHC 1+ platinum-resistant ovarian
cancer dose expansion cohort.
On behalf of my co-authors, I would like to thank the patients, their families and
caregivers, and all investigators and study staff involved in this
trial. Sincere thank you to Dr. Cheryl Pickett, who has been an
incredible champion of this study, and the staff at the NCI and CTAC.
Thank you to Daiichi Sankyo, AstraZeneca, and the Luen Foundation to Fight Women's
Cancers.
Thank you very much.
The next presenter is the discussant for this
presentation, Dr. Aditya Bardia from UCLA.
Good afternoon.
Thank you, co-chairs. Thank you, organizers. Thanks to Dr.
Linian Xu for inviting me as a discussant.
Excellent presentation by Dr. Li and team, and congrats to them for
conducting this important study.
It sets the stage for ADC-based combination
therapy, the next wave.
These are my financial disclosures.
So I'll review three things today.
I'll talk about work done in the field, what we've learned today,
as well as where the field is going.
Antibody drug conjugates essentially allow for selective
delivery of toxic payload.
The first step is binding of the ADC to the antigen.
The next step is internalization to form an early
endosome. Third is degradation of the ADC in
the lysosome.
Fourth is release of the payload,
and five, the payload exerting its effect
resulting in apoptosis. This has been the traditional
mechanism for an ADC. But newer
ADCs also have a bystander effect,
and this has been a game changer in the field of oncology
because it can address antigen heterogeneity
and can also allow ADCs to work in tumors that
have low expression of the antigen.
A poster child of this is trastuzumab deruxtecan, or
T-DXd. It has shown not only activity in
breast cancer that has high expression of HER2, but
also activity in tumors that have low expression of
HER2, including ultra-low HER2 positive breast
cancer.
Besides activity in breast cancer, T-DXd
has also demonstrated activity in other
HER2-expressing solid tumors, endometrial cancer,
cervical cancer, ovarian cancer, bladder cancer.And
indeed, in April of 2024,
the FDA approved trastuzumab deruxtecan, or
T-DXd, for patients who have solid
tumors that express HER2, or HER2-expressing
solid tumors. This is the first
tumor-agnostic approval of an ADC.
So now the question is: how can we improve the outcomes
further? How can we build combinations with
ADC?
In principle, one could develop
mechanistic combinations based on the payload.
So ADCs have a payload. Looking at the mechanism of the
payload, you can combine the ADC with a targeted
therapy. Let's talk about T-DXd
or other ADCs that have a TOP1 payload, such
as sacituzumab govitecan, datopotamab deruxtecan.
All of these have TOP1 inhibitors as the payload.
The TOP1 inhibitor is delivered to the cancer cell.
This results in the formation of TOP1cc's,
which are cleared by PARP. So potentially,
combining these drugs with a PARP inhibitor would
make mechanistic sense.
The challenge is overlapping toxicity.
Many of these ADCs cause myelosuppression, and
PARP inhibitors cause myelosuppression as well.
Indeed, in the past, when chemotherapy was combined with
PARP inhibitors,
it was very challenging to combine these drugs in clinic,
and the development of multiple combinations, irinotecan,
topotecan, with olaparib were discontinued.
In principle, it made sense. Irinotecan, topotecan, those are
TOP1 inhibitors, and combining that with a PARP inhibitor in
preclinical models showed synergy.
But in the clinic, the combination, because of toxicity, was very
difficult to develop.
But this changes with ADCs.
As was mentioned by Dr. Lee,
with an ADC, you have higher delivery of the
payload in the tumor microenvironment.
The payload is then cleared from normal cells, but because you have
higher delivery of the payload in the tumor microenvironment, it stays
there for a longer period of time. So if you wait for a few
days, you could potentially then add the PARP
inhibitor. So you give the ADC, wait for a few days, add the
PARP inhibitor. The payload is still in the tumor microenvironment,
so in the tumor microenvironment, the PARP inhibitor would
exert synergy.
Our team presented initial results at ACR a few years
ago where we asked this question of combining an ADC,
sacituzumab govitecan, that has a TOP1 inhibitor payload
with a PARP inhibitor. And the question was: will give them together
versus using a staggered schedule where SG is given
day one, day eight, every 21 days, and then the PARP inhibitor is
given in the off week. This was a translational study.
In the preclinical setting, the team had seen that in cell
lines, if you give SG and then wait for some
time and then add the PARP inhibitor, you see
higher synergy as compared to single agent, and you also
see that TOP1cc's are stabilized by using
the PARP inhibitor. Just giving SG alone, TOP1cc's are
cleared, but if you wait and then add the PARP inhibitor, you
see stabilization of TOP1cc's. So this was in the
preclinical setting. To test this hypothesis, looked at the
combination of the ADC with a PARP
inhibitor. Giving them together was too toxic.
With the concurrent schedule, 71% of patients had
DLT. But if you use a staggered schedule, none of
the patients had DLT. So the next question is: was this
combination active? And it was active.
With the concurrent schedule, it was very difficult to give that, but with
the staggered schedule, you could give both the ADC and
the PARP inhibitor, and you saw responses with this
combination.
At this meeting, now we've seen results related to T-DXd
plus olaparib. The team
looked at the combination in a continuous schedule, giving both these
drugs together, as well as this gap or staggered schedule
where T-DXd was given, and then on day eight to
14, olaparib was given. T-DXd is given every
21 days, so this allowed them to give the ADC,
wait for a few days, and then add the PARP inhibitor.
As was mentioned, giving them together was too toxic.
That was not feasible. But the staggered
schedule was still feasible, giving T-DXd followed by
olaparib.
And the advantage of the staggered schedule was that the side effects
were decreased, be it myelosuppression, be
it diarrhea, that was lower by giving
these drugs in a staggered fashion, and that's the principle or the
advantage of using these drugs in this sequence.
More importantly, the clinical activity was maintained.
You could see responses,
a partial response, as well as confirmed response by
using the ADC along with the PARP inhibitor.
Overall response rate of 54%. So the team
provided very important proof of principle that you can give these
drugs together. You just have to use them in a staggered
schedule.So the next question is
the elephant in the room, which is:
What does the combination add to monotherapy?
Is the activity of T-DXd plus olaparib
better than T-DXd alone?
If we look at the results of DESTINY-PanTumor-02, that
was a clinical trial that looked at T-DXd as a single agent
monotherapy.
In that trial, in endometrial carcinoma, the response
rate was 57.5%; in ovarian cancer, it
was 45%.
Now, I would caution with cross-trial comparisons between
DESTINY-PanTumor-02 and this study.
I think what we need is a step forward, which would be a randomized
study for patients with HER2-expressing advanced
platinum-resistant ovarian
and/or endometrial carcinoma, looking at T-DXd as a
single agent versus T-DXd plus a PARP
inhibitor in the staggered schedule.
Patients would receive the drug, and then you can really ask the question
of clinical activity of combination versus single agent.
You can look at PFS, OS response rate, as well as safety.
Now, as the trial is being designed, we need to consider a few things.
The first is biomarker selection.
Should this be a biomarker-driven study where
only patients with a certain biomarker that are more likely to respond from
combination are included, or does this become biomarker-enriched?
What are the stratification factors?
HER2 IHC 1+ versus 2+? Should you
also include HER2 ultra low, that is HER2
0+? And finally, the field has evolved.
Now we have PARP1 selective inhibitors.
So should the combination be with a PARP1 selective inhibitor,
which might have even lower toxicity?
So this is exciting and this is important because we are in an
ADC revolution. There's a growing number of
approvals in different cancers
and more than 100 ADC in clinical development across
tumors. The field is moving towards TOP1
inhibitor payloads.
Just last week at the annual meeting of women's cancer
SGO, we saw results of trastuzumab pirmatucan,
which showed a clinical activity of 50% in patients with
metastatic endometrial carcinoma.
At the same meeting, we saw sofimipitcan, another
ADC with a TOP1 inhibitor payload targeting folate
receptor, response rate close to 50%.
And in the same meeting, a third ADC, Morez, for
patients with metastatic endometrial ovarian carcinoma, another ADC
with a TOP1 inhibitor payload, response rate of 62%.
And with all these ADCs, potentially there's an opportunity of
combining them with a PARP inhibitor.
And that's just PARP inhibitor. Potentially, these drugs can
also be combined with other DDR agents, ATR,
CHEK, WEE1. So in the past, the combinations
of chemo with these drugs were abandoned, but now is the
opportunity of revisiting these combinations with
ADCs.
And that's just DDR agents. Potentially, these drugs can also
be combined with immunotherapy. When there is apoptosis, there's
activation in the tumor microenvironment, the immune cells,
T-cells that infiltrate with PD-1, PD-L1
that can be blocked. So if you use a PD-L1 inhibitor with ADCs,
with or without a PARP inhibitor, that could be synergistic, or
developing ADCs with bispecific payloads.
So in conclusion, ADCs have demonstrated
superior activity to chemo in various solid tumors, and there
are more than 100 in clinical development.
This tumor-selective payload delivery may
enable innovative drug scheduling to expand the
therapeutic window, such as combination with a TOP1
inhibitor payload with a PARP inhibitor.
This study and other studies have provided proof of principle, and
this merits additional evaluation.
There's also the opportunity of revisiting combinations with
other DDR agents. And overall as a field, we
need translational investigation of mechanistic
synergy related to ADC target payload processing
mechanism, and that would help us develop rational
ADC-based combinations. Thank you so much for your attention.
I believe we have time for one question.
Questions?
If not, I have a couple of questions.
I was wondering, I saw that several patients had
prior PARP, so I was wondering about the tolerability
of this combination in those patients, and also if you
considered selecting for patients who are BRCA
mutant.
I think just one patient was
BRCA mutant in your trial.
Yeah. So there were two patients who were BRCA mutants.
There was one patient who had a germline BRCA2 mutation and one patient with
a somatic BRCA1 mutation. We haven't looked specifically at the
tolerability of this combination in patients who have previously
received PARP inhibitors. But I do want to highlight again that the
dosing of the PARP inhibitor used, olaparib at 100 milligrams
dosed just for seven days, is below the
therapeutic dose that we would expect with a PARP inhibitor on its own
where typically the minimum dose is 100 milligrams twice daily
continuously.
And with that dosing, it is fairly tolerable.
Any other questions?
Yes.
So you showed that there were seven cases of pneumonia.
Do you think that the combination may actually exacerbate
the lung toxicity?
That's a great question, and I think we're realizing that ILD and the risk of
pneumonitis, with ADCs really is something we have to be
vigilant for,
and that we may be seeing higher rates in real-world experience
compared to what's been reported in clinical trials.
I think historically when we were starting to use
DS-8021A-T-DXd in our studies, we were
anticipating a rate of approximately 10%.
But as we're seeing more real-world reports emerge, really that's higher
and we're seeing rates of 15% up to 25%.
And in a single institution study, this was reported by my colleague, Dr.
Talia Lancman, at the Society of Gyn Onc last week.
In our institution in gynecologic cancer patients, it was a rate of about 20%.
So higher than expected based on the clinical trial reports.
It's very hard to say whether the one week of olaparib does
truly increase the incidence of ILD or pneumonitis.
Thank you.
We will have to move on. Just a quick reminder,
you can submit online your questions, so
please don't hesitate to do so.
Thank you.
Good work.
So we're going to move to the next presentation.
This is abstract CTO36, a
first-in-human study of a novel EGFR-targeted
antibody ADC in patients with advanced
nasopharyngeal carcinoma by Dr. Jian from
CSPC Pharmaceutical Group in China.
Good afternoon, everyone. It is my great pleasure
make the presentation on behalf of our study team.
Here, we report a first-in-human study result of a
novel EGFR-targeted ADC in patient with
advanced NPC.
This is my disclosure.
SOS
6010 is a humanized IgG1
antibody drug conjugate, which targeted at
EGFR with high drug antibody ratio
H, and the tumor selectable deliverable linker.
The payload GS1, which is a high potency and
a membrane permeable TOP1 inhibitor designed by
CSPC itself.
The antibody part has a highly affinity to
EGFR and the endocytosis efficiency
is speeded up. Based on the past general effect, the
cancer cells which do not
express EGFR also can be killed
by the investigational drug. The
well-designed molecular balances the
safety and efficacy, and finally deliver the clinical
benefit to NPC patient.
The study results
come from the NPC cohort from a multi-center phase one
trial, and the key eligibility criteria for
NPC cohort include subject should be pretreated
with platinum and immunotherapy,
and whether EGFR expression or not can be
enrolled.
There are two different dosage groups, which is
4.2 MPK Q3 and
4.8 MPK Q3 respectively.
And the primary endpoint are safety,
tolerability, and RP2d. The secondary
endpoint consisted of ORR, DUR, DCR,
PFS, and overall survival.
Finally, total
56 patient had been enrolled.
With 4.2 MPK Q3
dosage group, there are
34 patients, and in the
4.8 MPK
regimen, there are 22 patients respectively.
As two subjects withdrew from the trial, the efficacy
evaluable set consisted of 54 patients.
The data cut-off date is September 15th,
2025, and the median follow-up time is
11.5 months.
From the baseline characteristics between the two
regimen, the factor that impact on the efficacy and the
safety are generally balanced. For instance, median
age, gender, race, pathological diagnosis,
EGFR expression, metastatic sites, and
EGFR MAP pre-treatment history. Regarding the
EGFR PS score, the PS score zero patient
in 4.8 MPK regimen
group account for 4.5%, which
is much lower than that in another regimen group.
And for current clinical stage, the patient of
stage 4B enrolled in
4.8 MPK group represent
90.9%, which is higher than that
in 4.2 MPK
group.There are no clinical
meaningful differences by the TAE
and above Grade 3 TAE in different
regimen groups. Between the two groups above
Grade 3
RAE incidences are numerically very
close.
Dose reduction rate is higher in 4.8
mpk group with a number of
63.6% compared to that of the
another regimen,
23.5%.
From the diagram, we can see that the main above Grade
3 TAEs were hematological toxicities.
For instance, anemia, platelet count decreased,
white blood cell count decreased,
neutrophil count decreased,
lymphocyte count decreased,
which is a typically payload Top1 inhibitor-related
toxicities. And the EGFR target-related toxicities
are relatively much lower, with mouth
ulceration and diarrhea accounting for
4.5% respectively.
EpCAM by response rate was analyzed
in EpCAM evaluable set.
Combined the two dosage groups, the OR is
31.5% and the
4.8
milligram per kilogram group achieved a higher OR of
36.4%, compared to that of
the 4.2
regimen group,
28.1%, whether egfrimab
pre-treated or not, and among the different distinct metastatic
sites responses were observed.
Here we analyzed the duration of response.
The duration of response of total population is
7.4 months, and
4.8 milligram per kilogram
group achieved a numerically longer remission
duration. And within the same dosage group,
the DORs by egfrimab pre-treated or
naive are very close, which indicates
egfrimab usage history does not affect
DOR according to our clinical trial data.
The tumor kinetic analysis revealed that although
the tumor shrinkage continuously deepened when the
treatment in the first 18
weeks, the responders tumor sum of diameters
get a relatively early and dramatically
decreased trend. And compared the
4.2 mpk group,
the 4.8 mpk dosage group present a
trend of good tumor size control.
Combined the two dosage groups, the median PFS
was 7.5 months, and for
4.8 milligram per kilogram group,
the median PFS was 7.7 months.
For the
4.2
milligram per kilogram group, the median PFS was
7.4 months, respectively. Although the
median PFS between different regimen
is numerically closer,
4.8 mpk showed a better
trend. Finally, 4.8 mpk
Q3week was selected as a single agent RP2d.
This slide present that within the same dose
level, egfrimab naive patient achieved a higher
ORR for egfrimab pre-treated or
not. In 4.2 mpk group, the
ORR were
38.1% versus
9.1%. In
4.8 mpk regimen, the
OR were 40% versus
28.6%. For egfrima
naive patient, the different dose regimen resulted in the
closer response rate.
But for the patient pre-treated with egfrimab, the higher the dose
is, the higher the response rate is, which may indicate for
the patient who pre-treated with egfrimab require a
higher dosage to get a better effect.
From this slide, we can see that the purple lines
which present the egfrimab naive patient
demanding tumor size shrinking much deeper than
that of egfrimab pre-treated population.
Although 4.8 mpk group achieved a
deeper response, comparing the median PFS between different
dosage groups, they are very closer, which
indicates perhaps 4.2
mpk Q3 correct regimen also delivered a well
disease control.
The OS data was not mature, but by the data cut-off
date, the median OS, overall survival,
of 4.2 mpk group is
14.9 months, and the
median OS of the
4.8 mpk group is not
reached.As
we know that according to the mechanism of action of
ADC, extracellular receptor expression may
affect the treatment effects.
So we analyzed the EGFR expression level and the response rate
relationship in our trial. No clear signal was
observed between EGFR expression and the response
rate.
EBV is always seen as one of the significant
factor for NPC. In this
NPC cohort, 28 patients were
undergoing EBV testing, and 25 patients were EBV
positive. And the patient of EBV copy number above
1,500 at baseline accounts
for
67.8%. And after treatment,
57.1% of the baseline EBV
positive patient turned EBV undetectable.
And among the 16 patients who turned
EBV negative, five patient achieved PR accounting
for 31.2%. And
for the nine patients who did not get
EBV negative, only one patient was
evaluated as PR, accounting for
11.1%.
This is the summary and the conclusion of the study.
SYS61 demonstrated manageable safety
profile. Most common Grade 3
TEAEs were hematological toxicity, where
white blood cell count decreased, neutral count
decreased, and platelet count decreased.
Non-hematological Grade 3 TEAE were infrequent.
SYS610 demonstrated encouraging
anti-tumor activity in advanced NPC patient.
OR was 31.5%
in efficacy evaluable NPC patient,
and 28.1
in 4.2 milligram per
kilogram Q3 week group, and
36.6 in
4.8 milligram per kilogram Q3 week
group. OR was
28.6%
for 4.2
mpk Q3 week dose and
40% for
4.8 mpk Q3 week dose
in EGFR map naive patient. Further
exploration on
SYS610 combination with the
PD-1 map in NPC are ongoing.
Here we thank all the patient and their family for
their participation. We also thank all the study staff
for their contribution. This study is supported by CFPC
Megalis Biopharmaceutical company, and all
authors contributed and approved the presentation.
Sincerely thank you.
Wonderful. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Now this paper will be discussed by Dr.
Anna Spreafico from the Princess Margaret Cancer Center in
Toronto. Anna.
Good afternoon, everyone. It's a pleasure to be here.
I'd like to thank the organizing committee for the opportunity to
discuss this study, and I want to congratulate the
authors for their important work that brings
further hope for the treatment management of NPC.
Here's my disclosures.
At first, I just want to briefly summarize the data we heard.
Today we heard the expansion cohort results of
SYS6010 delivered in a heavily pretreated
patient population of nasopharyngeal cancer, previously
exposed to chemoimmunotherapy, and some of whom also
receive EGFR monoclonal antibody therapy
prior to being enrolled in the study.
This study was run in Asia. In terms of key
safety message, we saw a high
percentage of
high-grade toxicity, 61%, mainly hematologic,
but often with a short recovery time
and a discontinuation rate that was quite low, although toxic deaths were
seen.
In terms of key activity message, we saw a
objective response rate of 31% with a
high disease control rate and a median
progression-free survival that is in the mid
to high single digits.
Particularly interesting was the subgroup of patients,
EGFR monoclonal antibody naive, so did not receive the monoclonal
antibody prior to that. Objective response rate was higher, suggesting
that perhaps the antigen integrity and function do
matter. I think this is an important study in
the recurrent metastatic setting for nasopharyngeal cancer.
Aside from the standard of care therapy, which is first line
chemoimmunotherapy, we don't really have other treatment
option or strong data with respect to other treatment
option. And EGFR, it's actually highly expressed in
this disease. Therefore, the rationale of
EGFR-based antibody drug conjugate, it's actually
quite straightforward. Hit the target because we know it's
important, but increase the activity with perhaps a
strong cytotoxic payload,
and there are already encouraging dataSo
SYS6010, it's a humanized anti-EGFR monoclonal
antibody
drug conjugate that is linked
with a cleavable linker to a TOP1 inhibitor
with a high drug to antibody ratio.
Once the target is recognized after internalization
and cleavage, there is a release of the payload that leads to
DNA damage and cell death. And this drug was really
developed in order to have a stronger effect on the
EGFR expressor, although we saw a bystander effect.
When we're looking at the drug development portfolio in nasopharyngeal
cancer,
as many other type of cancer, there are a plethora of
drugs and combinations such as immunotherapy combination, EV
targeted vaccine, bispecific antibody, and
antibody drug conjugate are actually rising as an important
type of therapy in this setting. However, we
should consider them with the standard idea of
are they going to outlive the world real
practice?
For that, I've tried with this slide and this table to
provide you a very broad landscape of
EGFR-based antibody drug conjugate and
EGFR-based non-antibody drug conjugate
and situate 6010 as well as other
agents within the context of the timeline development.
The main concept that I'm hoping to share with
you today is that this is not a single target
story. This is a rapidly moving field with
multiple platform as well as multiple payloads.
And the question is, which of these drug is going to
become the next standard of care?
To do so, I digged a little bit into the literature and I
provided in the next couple of slides some summary
data comparing the data from 6010
to, for example, the early data, so the EGFR-based
antibody drug conjugate early phase clinical trial
with similar and other disparity payloads.
And as we can see here, the common theme that
emerged is that objective response rate are seen in certain
tumor types such as nasopharyngeal cancer, and not
in others such as glioblastoma. But however, the
trade-off seems to be always the
high toxicity rate.
And similar...
It's not advancing.
Similar conclusions appear when I compare
the 6010 to more mature data of the phase three
trials of other EGFR-based
antibody drug conjugate,
where again, response rates were high,
but toxicity remain, again, the limiting factors with TOP1
being hematologic.
And then ultimately, I benchmarked the
SYS6010 with other
non-EGFR-based antibody drug conjugate using, for example,
the LY201, which is a
B7-H3 ADC with
similar TOP1 payload and a high DAR.
Again, high response rate and high toxicity,
mainly hematological.
So from a clinical standpoint, two conclusion
emerge.
There is a toxicity signature, how I called it.
So therefore, the choice of the antibody drug conjugate matter
because it's going to define the toxicity and
therefore the safety measures we need to put in place for treating our
patients safely. For example, for TOP1, we see a
strong myelosuppression, and it's often a trade-off for high
response.
But also the disease and the biology matter.
In epithelial tumors such as NPC, we're seeing strong
responses with accessible antigen and high
EGFR expression. However, in other tumor types such as
glioblastoma, despite the biomarker selection, we still don't
see any benefit. Why is that so? Is that a resistant clone or
other mechanisms? So we do need more data in this space.
I'd like to conclude with three point of discussion.
We heard that 6010 has a predictable and manageable toxicity in the
protocol-driven care delivery with low rate of
discontinuation. So I ask myself whether or not this is going to be
feasible in the real world data. And whether or not using this
drug in an unstructured use will compromise the trial proven
benefit. And to do so, I looked at serious aspect of
this ADC and compare it to chemotherapy.
Certainly, from an activity standpoint, ADC is superior,
but it saw also the hematological, particularly acute
toxicity that we see that definitely require a
higher monitoring intensity in order to mitigate
the risk that are actually quite higher of discontinuation if we did not do
safely. So therefore, ADC are potentially
better in controlling this disease in the real world
setting, but we need to adjust to that.
We're just very used to chemotherapy, but we cannot pretend
to use this drug
like we do with chemotherapy. And the scalability success
may actually depend more on the care of the delivery design rather than
a future efficacy gain.Second,
we saw meaningful activity in heavily pretreated nasopharyngeal
cancer patients. So strategically, I ask whether or not we should
bring this
treatment option earlier in earlier lines
and I do know that there are study ongoing, so be interesting to see
the results. But also as more study advance, I would
advocate to make sure that all patients with
nasopharyngeal cancer, both the non-keratinizing, but also the
more rare non-endemic NPC are included.
And also, how does this compare to other ADC?
We saw, for example, of
YL201 B7-H3. I think
we don't have the answer yet. I think that
toxicity as well as potential signal of activity are similar,
so the game is the same in this space.
And then finally, a stronger signal of EGFR antibody-naive
patients was seen, and therefore that advocates for
more biomarker study in order to identify and select better the
patients that might respond to this therapy, and what are the mechanisms
of dual targeted combination, as well as mechanisms
of resistant. And with this, I want to thank the patients, obviously, the family,
the caregiver, and the entire research community. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much. This paper is now open for
questions. You can either go to the microphone, identify yourself
please, or you can use the online system.
Oh, hi there. Nathaniel Wiest, Mayo Clinic.
Congratulations on the clinical trial.
There is data that the type of the
cleaver is correlated to toxicity with ADCs, and I believe
it was a cleavable linker that was used.
Is there any exploration or rationale for a cleavable versus
a non-cleavable linker? Do you think that could potentially help with the toxicity
problem?
Okay. This is a very good question for ADC design.
As we know that most of the ADC with the
payload of MMAE or Trop-1
inhibitor
there are high incidences of
hematological toxicities.
The reason of this
is that
the ADC
delivered in
blood
and the linker
stable is very important for the
payload release.
So the cleavable linker and the non-cleavable linker
is very important for the toxicities.
According to my perspective,
I think a more stable linker will
decrease
the toxicity of hematology.
And
the cleavable linker will enhance
the
best gender effect one ADC
was delivered to
tumor tissue.
So I think there is not
a clear answer. It is should be balanced from the
stable linker and
the cleavable linker,
so that we can get a good performance
in clinical data. Thank you.
I have one. Go ahead, please.
So Irene Brana from Vall d'Hebron University Hospital in Spain.
So I would like if you could elaborate a little bit more on the treatment-related
Grade 3 adverse events, and especially like to understand
which kind of events they are and if there is any strategy to prevent
going to Phase 2, Phase 3 development.
Okay. This is a very good question.
I think that from the pharmaceutical perspective
to go to the
Phase 3 trial or not depends on
several aspects. For instance,
the
need
and the medical needs. First of all is the medical needs.
And the second one is the regulatory
chances in the region country.
As presented
previously
, there are many ADC
targeted at different targets such as
B7-H3 and other targets
ADC.
So
according to our strategy, we
are doing the clinical trial combined with
immunotherapy for the first-line NPC.
So based on the data in future we
acquired, we will go to the Phase 3 trial
in first line NPC. Thank you.
Can I just add, I think what Irene has asked is highly
relevant because as more of these drugs are in
development, we are kind of adjusted to
this type of toxicity, right? We were with other treatment,
immunotherapy, for example. I think my message was that we also need
to learn how to manage that and
sometimes preventing themWe have
example with other compounds, immunotherapy, we've been able to manage
certain toxicities. So I think it's about adapting and
learning more about how we manage it from a
clinical perspective. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Okay, our next presenter
.
Our next presenter is Dr. Tao Zhu from Zhejiang
Cancer Hospital from Hangzhou, China, and he will be
presenting a first-in-human Phase 1 trial of a novel
claudin VI targeting antibody-drug conjugate,
QLS-5132, in patients with
platinum-resistant ovarian cancer. Dr.
Zhu
.
Good afternoon, distinguished chairperson and
colleagues. I'm Dr. Zhu Tao from
Zhejiang Hospital,
Hangzhou, China.
On behalf of my co-investigators, I
would like to thank the committee over selecting this
study.
I'm great honor to present the
result from the first in-human Phase 1 study of the
novel claudin VI targeting ADC.
This is my
disclosure information.
Let's talk about the background. Claudin
VI
is a key protein in intercellular
tight junction. It helps form
cell junction and guide stem cell
differentiation. Most important, claudin
VI is barely detectable in
normal adult tissue, but is
highly expressed in many cancers like ovarian cancer or
lung cancer, and is linked to poor
prognosis.
As you can see, this TCGA plot,
claudin VI expression is much higher in
tumor tissue than in normal tissue, especially
in ovarian cancer.
Next, the strat we investigate,
QLS-5132,
is a highly selective claudin VI targeting ADC.
As shown in the diagram, we can see
three parts of this drug: a humanized
anti-claudin antibody, a
stable hydrazonic linker, and
a TOP1 inhibitor
payload with a drug-to-antibody ratio of
eight.
The drug showed an expanded therapy
window and potential antitumor activity in
PROC.
Then we can see the study design. This is the
first in-human Phase 1 study of
QLS-5132, consists
of dose
escalation and expansion phase
to evaluate the safety and RP2D
of the drug in patients with solid tumor.
For the inclusion criteria, eligible patients
were adults with advanced solid tumor,
failed and/or no standard therapy.
ECOG performance status zero
or one. We used ATD and the Bohmann
design, giving
QLS-5132 IV
infusion once every three weeks,
with dose from one point six and
finally to six point four.
Based on evaluated data, we expanded into
five cohort.
Till now, the expansion cohort focused on
PCOR at four point eight and
five point
six.
Then we can-- Sorry.
Then we can see the baseline character.
A total of twenty-eight patients with
PROC were recruited.
Ninety-two point nine percent patient
had ovarian cancer. These patients were
heavily pretreated. The median number of
prior lines of treatment was three, from
one to six.
Eighty-nine
point
three percent patients received befar, and
twenty-two
cases received PARP inhibitor.
We have the safety summary.
A favorable safety profile was shown.
We observed one DLT in one patient
at a six point four dose level,
which is a Grade 4 platelet count decrease.
Fully recovered to
baseline.MTD was not
reached.
Looking at the data,
92.9% of patients had any
grade TVs, and
32.1% had grade
3 and high TVs. Importantly, no TVs
lead to
death or treatment
discontinuation.
Let's talk more about the safety detail.
Most TVs were GI and
hemotoxicities, as you can see here.
And the major was grade 1 or 2, which
means we were mild to moderate,
especially at the potentially
RP2D dose level.
At the
6.4 dose level, we
have 66.7% of patients
experienced grade 3 or high hemo
TVs.
In addition, no inter institutional
lung disease occurred, toxicity and
so on occurred.
Let's see the key
efficiency results. Best
overall resource.
Use resist on 18
patients were in EES or nine
patient, which is 50% achieve
PR, and five of them achieve
confirmed PR.
As you can see in this waterfall plot,
tumor shrinkage was observed in most
patients.
Looking at the dose level,
at 4.8 mDoS,
the ORR was
55.6%. At dose
3.2 and higher, the ORR was
52.9%.
Besides, two patients with undetectable
CLDN6 expression also achieved PR,
maybe due to the small
sample size. So no significant
correlation between CLDN6
expression and response was seen.
Then we look at the duration response data,
which show the duration of the drug's efficiency.
First, the swing plot tracks each
patient treated duration among
the nine patients who achieved PR.
Five maintained their response for over three
months. These patients were treated at a
3.2 and a 4.8 dose level.
More importantly, at the
3.2 dose level, all patients who achieved
PR has response last more than
six months, showing duration
anti-tumor activity.
This spider plot tracks tumor burden
can change over time, and you can see clear and
sustained tumor shrinking in most PR
patients.
Across all dose levels, the median
relative
dose
intensity was
99.8%.
This is PK.
PK exposure increase in
the dose range of
1.6 to 6.4. The median
elimination half-life was more
than 5.5 days, which support the
once every three weeks closure
schedule. Important, the mean
molar ratio of released
payload to ADC,
AUC, was less than
0.2%.
So its conclusion,
QRS-5132 was
well-tolerated with wider therapeutic
windows, especially at potential
RP2D dose level of
4.8 and 5.6. It
showed remarkable anti-tumor
activity in patients with PROC, with
an ORR of 15% across
overall dose levels and
55% at 4.8.
In addition, patients with low
undetectable CLDN6 expression
still show clinical response.
Enroll in PROC,
non-small cell cancer, gastric cancer and
other cancer are going.
As last, I would like to express many thanks
toAll the patients and the families
investigates and personal in each
study site
the AACR
2026 Congress committee
and the meeting chairpersons and all the
audience. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Our next presentation is by Dr. Ramez Eskander
from USCD Moore's Cancer Center.
Dr. Eskander.
Thank you to the program committee.
Thank you so much for the kind introduction. I would like to congratulate Dr.
Zhu and his colleagues on the work that was done examining this
novel claudin-6 targeting antibody-drug conjugate.
And it's my humble pleasure to be here today to talk about antibody-drug
conjugates in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer, a turning
point or temporary promise?
My disclosures are shown above.
As was already reviewed today by prior discussants, we're living
in an era where we have really
significant antibody-drug conjugate development.
If we look at marketed ADC payloads, we see that these
are slightly preponderant by tubulin
disruptors. But if we look at those that are in phase three trials, we
could see an even distribution between microtubule disrupting
payloads as well as topoisomerase one inhibitors accounting for approximately
90% of the total treatment strategy.
Thankfully, in the gynecologic cancer arena, we already have
FDA-approved antibody drug conjugates.
Trastuzumab deruxtecan targeting tissue factor with a microtubule disrupting
payload, accelerated approval, followed by full approval
independent of tissue factor expression.
Mirvetuximab soravtansine, a folate receptor alpha
targeting ADC biomarker selected in an FR alpha high
population,
again accelerated to full approval.
And trastuzumab deruxtecan as already reviewed today in a disease agnostic
manner in HER2 3+, again, biomarker selected
population. But as you can see from the bottom of the slide, there are several
other ADC targets that are areas of active investigation.
Trop-2 targeting ADCs, B7H4, cadherin 6,
and claudin 6, which we'll review today.
The rationale for why we are looking at ADCs as therapeutic targets
is clear. We're looking to expand the therapeutic window.
And as was already alluded to, claudin 6 has strong biologic
rationale. It's an embryologic tight junction
antigen that's expressed in early embryonic
cells with limited expression in normal adult tissue, and some
would call this as tumor specific an antigen as we can try to
elicit.
In addition, if we look at prognostic implications, there has
been retrospective assessments that suggest that claudin 6
expression is associated with poor clinical outcomes.
So it gives us both strategic opportunities to take
advantage of.
I would like to first talk a moment about the relevance of prior therapy.
As Dr. Zhu alluded to already in the presentation that he gave us a
moment ago,
prior bevacizumab use was accounted for.
We don't really have clinical data that informs that prior bevacizumab
exposure should compromise response to subsequent
anticancer-directed therapy. And in fact, we can use bevacizumab in sequence
with preserved clinical benefit in the gynecologic cancer arena.
Conversely, there may be a strong relevance to prior PARP inhibitor exposure,
which in the aggregate population enrolled was approximately 80%.
And why might that be the case? Because we're learning from data that was
presented by Dr. Coleman and others, aggregate clinical trial
data, that prior PARP exposure and progression may
compromise response to subsequent systemic treatment options.
And this is important as we try to contextualize the magnitude of benefit when
we're looking at clinical efficacy.
Here, if we look at the data that was presented by Dr.
Coleman, you could see that although these patients are platinum sensitive in
recurrence, when we rechallenge them with platinum or non-platinum doublets
in the third line or greater, the response rate does not exceed
20% and the median progression-free survival is approximately six months.
That's about half of what we see in a PARP inhibitor-naive
population.
We're also discovering that prior cytotoxic exposure may impact
antigen expression. So this was preclinical work that showed that
carboplatin exposed cell lines and also animal
models will enrich claudin 6 expression.
So as we think about the efficacy data that was presented today in the
platinum resistant population, prior platinum exposure, if we
look to move these therapeutic strategies up into earlier lines of therapy, are we
going to see the same magnitude of benefit based on target antigen
expression levels if that is relevant for efficacy?
So here I just wanted to take a moment to summarize the efficacy data.
If we look at the efficacy evaluable population,
the objective or overall response rate was approximately 50%.
But importantly, we didn't have efficacy data on each of the examined
doses. We had an ORR of 55% at
the 4.8 milligram per kilogram dose,
but we also see that the contribution
of the target in informing efficacy remains unclear.
So the question we have to ask ourselves, not just for this specific claudin 6
targeting ADC, but for all ADCs, is this a target dependent
response? Is it a dose dependent response?
Is it likely a combination of both?
And we know already that claudin 6 expression has significant inter-patient
variability as illustrated from a paper looking at various tumor
samples.But also within the tumor itself with
solidness as well as areas of fragmented tumor showing
substantial heterogeneity. And this does not account for spatial and
temporal changes over time.
And why is this relevant for us? Because I don't think we can continue to
develop antibody-drug conjugates without investing time
in more concretely identifying the relevance of the target
antigen. This is data from Vicki Macker and colleagues showing the
discordance between local and central HER2 for the DESTINY pan-tumor O2 and
the GYN cohort. And you can see that the discordance is
approximately 50% with some local HER2
3+ being central HER2 1+ or zero. And if it
really does matter for the ADC that we're investigating, can we
afford to have such substantial discrepancy?
And we need to become smarter. We need to use computational pathology,
AI, digital pathology, ctDNA strategies.
There's a wonderful paper talking about the evolution of how we score
HER2 as we develop additional novel therapeutic
drugs.
And I would argue that we can't afford to necessarily be biomarker
agnostic for ADCs. So this was Dr. Hasegawa
and colleagues looking at 80 high-grade serous ovarian cancer patients,
HER2 negative, FR alpha negative.
But you can see in this one patient population, 40% to
60% high expression of claudin 6-- Excuse me,
cadherin 6, B7H4 or Trop-2.
Every one of these has ADCs in drug development.
So we're going to think about how do I sequence this?
When we look at these antigenic targets, many of which, again,
have confirmatory phase three studies ongoing,
I have a patient in front of me in clinic, and I'm going to be obligated to have to
choose what is the right antibody-drug conjugate.
So this is a hypothetical H&E slide that was created in a patient that's FR
alpha high, claudin 6 positive, but intermediate, and
Trop-2 positive low. And when I have multiple ADCs that are
approved in clinical practice and potentially adding to this a claudin 6 targeting
ADC, what data am I going to use to help inform what I use
first, and what's the rational reason that I'm going to
sequence these drugs in the way to maximize clinical
benefit for the patient in front of me?
We also contextualize the data by taking into context
other claudin 6 ADCs in development.
This is TORAL-123. This is a claudin 6 targeting
ADC with an MMAE payload. Dr. Konechny shared the efficacy
data at the 2.4 and three milligram doses ranging from
42% to 50%. You could see here the treatment-related
adverse events, which predominantly were hematologic,
consistent with what was shared, and mitigated by growth factor.
And you can look at the CATALINA 2.0, which is the randomized dose optimization,
which includes growth factor with each of the doses being examined.
So again, we live in a dynamic time.
These are ADCs that are furthest along in
development in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer.
And I pull them here because I want to bring your attention to the fact that the
ORRs are remarkably similar across every one of these
antibody-drug conjugates, ranging from approximately 50% to
55%. Three of these four, the highlighted ones in yellow, are
not biomarker selected, while on the very far right,
torvusam is technically biomarker selected, FR alpha
25%, 1+ or greater, but that's a very large proportion of the
population. And of course, we have to take into consideration the
adverse event profile as it relates to these agents.
So 12% to 17% greater than or equal to Grade 3 HemaEs, as
was reported by Dr. Zhu for the claudin 6 targeting ADC with a
Tropo-1 payload. But we also have to be thoughtful about what combinations
might look like. We saw with mirvetuximab plus carboplatin
at SGO that the pneumonitis rate adjudicated in that
study when you gave mirvetuximab plus carboplatin was approximately
15%, 19 patients higher than single agent.
And we see a slew of Tropo-1 payloads, which really begs the question:
What are we going to do in clinical practice?
These are phase three ADC maintenance trials in the first line and in
the platinum-sensitive setting.
So we're already moving Tropo-1 payload ADCs into the
frontline and to the platinum-sensitive recurrent population.
So now when we talk about the platinum-resistant cohort, what does that mean for
sequencing? Are we going to be able to rationally sequence these drugs and
show clinical benefit? We know with the LY417 that
was already referenced earlier in the first discussion slide, prior
mirvetuximab exposure was there, prior topotecan, and we still
saw clinical benefit. And are there novel ADC
strategies that are going to improve clinical outcomes for our patients?
Just briefly, peptide drug conjugates, immune stimulatory
antibody drug conjugates, and prodrug antibody
conjugates.
And just for reference, this is a schematic that shows us the dramatic
overlap in the design of ADC-based clinical
strategies in platinum-resistant ovarian cancer with nine
ongoing trials or nine studies planned.
So in the last one to two years, we've seen a really pronounced
explosion of ADCs across disease settings.
But we are obligated to dose optimize, as was already referred to today.
Regimen optimization, that's not a problem in platinum-resistant disease where
patients aren't expected to achieve a meaningful remission, but it's
absolutely our obligation in platinum-sensitive and frontline where remission is
anticipated. How are we going to sequence these, and does biomarkers matter?
And ultimately incorporating novel ADC construct. I'd like to thank Dr.
Zhu and his colleagues, congratulating them once again, and it was a pleasure to be
here with you today. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Any questions from the room?
Hit record.
Okay.
Okay, no question?
We--
Yes.
Thank you for an awesome presentation.
So I am from the LG Chem in Korea. I have a quick question about your
antibody. So you know most of our
antibody against claudin six has their data keeps
saying they're very specific binding, but sometimes
claudin six and claudin nine has only three difference of
amino acids, so it is very hard to get those real
specific antibody against claudin six only.
So I'm wondering if your antibody's profile is real.
Is a specific claudin six binding antibody.
Only claudin six-
Exactly
... or higher than?
No, only claudin six binding.
Thank you.
Thank
you. Any other questions? Yes.
Hi.
I'm a co-author of the study. Just a very
good discussion and very good points.
Just wanted to supplement some information.
So first, probably Dr. Chu didn't have time to
elaborate how we designed this molecule.
So one feature of this ADC is that
the payload, even it's a TOP1 inhibitor, but
we have changed, make its t1/2 shorter
after departure from the antibody.
So in this way, it can be quickly
cleared from a system.
Yes.
So this is why we anticipate, and we saw in
preclinical studies, we're glad to see in clinical studies
also, we have a lower hematological toxicity.
So this is one thing I want to mention.
The other thing is, from our limited data, we found that
the samples we collected from clinic, if you check the
expression of claudin six
from platinum sensitive
tumors, ovarian cancers versus
platinum resistant,
we did not see
significant change of claudin six expression.
But I think you make a very good point.
Again, the size of the sample is still
limited. We still need to continue to see
what's happened. So I just wanted to add something here. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yes.
Hi, my name's Ahmed. I'm a GI oncology fellow at Walter Reed. Dr.
Skender, I have a question. How do you see us getting out of this developing
clinical conundrum of trying to figure out what is the best ADC?
Do we need head-to-head trials or what comes next?
I think we will learn from other solid tumors because there are
ADCs that are going to be approved in the same setting.
I don't believe-- You'll hear some people say one and done.
My genuine belief is that we are not going to be one and done in any disease
setting. We're going to have several antibody drug conjugates that are likely going
to be approved,
and it's going to be our obligation to begin to make sense of how we
choose. I alluded to it in the slide.
At the end of the day, as a clinician and a researcher, I have
to make a thoughtful recommendation for the patient sitting in front of me.
And that's why my desire is
even if we develop ADCs that may ultimately not be biomarker
restricted per se for efficacy because standard of care
chemotherapy is just very ineffective in those disease settings,
let us figure out what the differential efficacy is so that when that patient's
sitting in front of us in clinic and we know their antigenic repertoire,
I can try to make an informed decision.
But I also think that we are going to see an evolution, I didn't have enough time
to go into it, but the type of ADCs in development, and this is
kind of first generation or second, and just like we saw with the WE1, we're going
to see, hopefully over time, really meaningful drug development
advances in this space.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
So we want to move to the final presentation this
afternoon, Abstract CTO38.
This is the results of the ARTEMIS-101,
phase one study, which is a combination of
REVSYBOO, tagretucumab, and
atezolizumab in previously treated advanced non-squamous,
non-small cell lung cancer without actionable genomic
alterations. Presented by Dr. Zhong from Shanghai
Chest Hospital.
Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen, it's a great honor to join you at AACR this year.
I'm Runbo Zhong from Shanghai Chest Hospital.
On behalf of the principal investigator, Professor Huazhong, and all the
co-investigators, we'd like to sincerely thank the AACR
committee for the opportunity to present the results of ARTEMIS-101,
a phase one trial of REVSYBOO tagretucumab, a B7-H3
ADC, plus atezolizumab, a PD-L1 inhibitor,
in patients with advanced non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer
without actionable genomic alterations.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
Now in today's presentation, I'll be introducing the efficacy and safety
of REVSYBOO tagretucumab, Revesib for short,
a novel B7-H3 targeting tropomodulin one inhibitor
ADC in combination with atezolizumab, a PD-L1 inhibitor,
in previously treated non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer patients
without actionable genomic alterations.
The combination achieved a confirmed ORR of
47.1% and a median PFS 14 months
based on the preliminary data.And efficacy was observed
across the B7-H3 and the PD-L1 expression levels
and regardless of prior immunotherapy exposure.
The combination showed a clinically meaningful efficacy over the historical
benchmarks for both rezurock monotherapy and the current
standard
second line of care, the docetaxel.
Rezurock plus atezolizumab showed a manageable safety profile with no new
safety signals identified. And the
preliminary efficacy and safety results support
the further development of the combination in non-small cell lung cancer.
B7-H3 is an immune checkpoint protein with limited
expression in normal tissues, but upregulated in many
cancers, including lung cancer.
B7-H3 is not only highly expressed in small cell lung cancer, which
many of us are familiar with, but also showed substantial
expression in non-small cell lung cancer.
The high B7-H3 expression is
associated with reduced survival.
Rezurock is a B7-H3 ADC linked to a
tropomysin-1 inhibitor
via a protease cleavable linker,
the DAR is four. Atezolizumab is a PD-L1
inhibitor, which has been approved for the first-line treatment of
extensive stage small cell lung cancer in China.
Rezurock monotherapy previously reported the encouraging efficacy in
multiple solid tumors, including small cell lung cancer and non-small cell lung
cancer.
In previously treated non-squamous non-small cell lung cancer without
AGAs,
rezurock monotherapy showed a confirmed ORR of
33.3% and a median PFS of seven months.
Here we reported efficacy and safety of rezurock plus
atezolizumab in previously treated non-squamous non-small cell lung cancer patients
without AGAs from the Phase 1 trial, Artemis101.
Now moving on to the study design of Artemis101.
The Phase 1 trial consists of dose escalation and dose expansion phases.
The data we are presenting today focus on the expansion
cohort of pretreated non-squamous non-small cell cancer without
AGAs.
Now looking at the key eligibility criteria.
We enrolled patients aged 18 years and older with
ECOG performance status of zero to one.
The target population is pretreated non-squamous non-small cell
lung cancer without AGAs, specifically those with
progression or intolerance of the platinum-based therapy.
For treatment, patients received the rezurock eight milligram per
kilogram plus atezolizumab 20 milligram per kilogram
of the mini IV every three weeks.
And as noted at the bottom, these doses were
selected by the Safety Review Committee for expansion following
completion of the dose escalation phase.
While the primary endpoints of the overall Phase 1
trial was MAD or MTD,
the expansion cohort is designed to further
evaluate the efficacy and safety of the combination therapy at the
selected dose.
As of the data cutoff, January 20, 2026,
a total of 40 patients were enrolled.
All of the patients were included in the safety set, and
34 patients were included in the efficacy evaluable set.
Here are the patients' baseline characteristics and treatment exposure.
As of the data cutoff, a total of 40 patients were enrolled, and all
of them had adenocarcinomas.
The median number of prior therapy was one.
As shown in the table, all of the patients received prior
chemotherapy, and 75% of the patients
received prior immunotherapy. And even two patients
were previously treated with the investigational ADCs
targeting Trop-2 or PD-L1.
In terms of the PD-L1 expression,
37.5% were negative,
22.5% were positive. The rest were
unassessable.
The median exposure for both rezurock and atezolizumab was
8.5 cycles.
Now looking at the efficacy of the combination therapy.
After median follow-up of 11.7 months among the
34 patients in the efficacy evaluable set,
the combination achieved a confirmed ORR of
47.1%, median DOR of 12.6
months with a DCR of
94.1%.
As shown in the complement curve on the right, the median
PFS was 14 months with upper bond not yet
reached. Twelve months PFS rate of
67.7% and the median overall
survival data remain immature.
And as shown, looking at the waterfall plot on the left,
efficacy was consistent across B7-H3 expression
levels and independent of prior immunotherapy
exposure with the confirmed ORR of
52.2% in the pretreated patients
and 44.4% in the
immunotherapy-naïve patients.
The swim plot illustrates the duration of the treatment.
With a median follow-up of 11.7 months, 15 patients,
which is
44.1%, were still on the treatment.
And as shown in the figure14 patients have
received the study treatment for more than one year,
crossing the 52 weeks line,
with the longest treatment duration exceeding
14.5 months and still ongoing.
The slide illustrates the efficacy by baseline PD-L1 expressions.
There are 23 patients who were available for PD-L1
expression.
Antitumor activities were observed across the
PD-L1 subgroups.
In the PD-L1 positive population, the combination
achieved a confirmed ORR of 62.5%,
12-month PFS rate of 87.5%.
These are numerically higher than those in the PD-L1 negative
population, which showed a confirmed ORR of
33.3%, 12-month PFS rate of
53.6%.
Regarding the safety profile,
the combination were generally well-tolerated.
Grade 3 or higher TRAEs occurred in 70% of the patients,
predominantly hematological toxicities, and manageable.
TRAEs leading to dose reduction occurred in 20%
of the patients. Treatment discontinuation
in 15% of the patients. No TEAEs leading to
death were observed.
In term of the iOD events, which is of special interest
for ADCs, only four cases of
treatment-related iOD were reported, and all of
these events were mild, specifically Grade 1 or
2.
Now let's take a closer look at the details of the safety profile.
Most common Grade 3 or high TRAEs were
hematological toxicities, including white blood cell count
decrease, neutrophil, lymphocyte count decrease, and
anemia.
Beyond the hematological toxicities, the other most common events
were nausea and vomiting, which were mostly low-grade and
manageable.
The safety profile of the combination were consistent with the known
toxicities of risdiplam and adeblimab.
In conclusion, the combination of risdiplam and adeblimab
demonstrated encouraging antitumor activity in previously
treated non-squamous non-small cell lung cancer patients like mutations,
with a confirmed ORR of 47.1% and a median
PFS of 14 months based on the preliminary data,
representing meaningful improvement over the historical
benchmarks of risdiplam monotherapy and docetaxel.
Also, the combination showed a manageable safety profile with no new safety
signals identified.
Based on these preliminary safety and efficacy results, a Phase 3
trial of risdiplam plus adeblimab in
non-squamous non-small cell lung cancer patients without AGs as
second-line is currently on the way.
And finally, we'd like to thank all the patients and their families for their
commitment to the study, as well as the investigators and
the sponsor staff for their support. Thank you very much for your attention.
And now this paper will be discussed by Dr.
Melissa Johnson from the Sarah Cannon Research Institute in
Nashville.
Like to thank the organizers for the opportunity to participate as a
discussant in this session, and thank you all for staying to the
bitter end.
In the next 10 minutes, it's my pleasure to
discuss
Artemis 101: Defining the Benefit of
B7H3 Antibody Drug Conjugates in Combination with
PDL1. Is this signal synergy or a statistical
chance?
Here are my disclosures, all payments paid to my institution.
So over the next 10 minutes, we'll talk about B7H3.
We'll talk about what we know about B7H3 antibody drug
conjugates and what the clinical benefit could be for
adding checkpoint inhibitors PDL1
and PD-1.
And then we'll look at what we've learned from other antibody drug
conjugates in the space for the treatment of non-small cell lung
cancer.
B7H3 is a novel checkpoint. It's
part of the B7H superfamily. It's expressed on
antigen-presenting cells and tumor.
And we see that it's expressed
quite ubiquitously among human tumor tissues, although
not at all on normal tissues. For the sake of today's
discussion, I'll point out that it is expressed
highly in squamous and non-squamous non-small cell
lung cancer.
So there are as many as eight B7H3 antibody drug
conjugates that are in the clinic currently, and actually the
first made by MacroGenics was discontinued in 2025.
So ifenatumab, durxatumumab, iDXd
was one of the first to hit the clinic.
It was actually a collaboration between Daiichi Sankyo and
Sarah Cannon, and thus enrolled both US patients
and patients from Japan. There were about 100 patients treated in
this Phase 1 trial, and I think we were
pleasantly surprised to note
fairly manageable toxicities early on.
We evaluated a number of dose levels.
You can see in the top right that irrespective of dose
from 6.4 all the way up to 16 milligrams per kilogram, we saw
activity. And what was perhaps the most
uhExciting for a phase one doctor was the number of different
tumor types where we saw activity.
So we saw activity in squamous
esophageal lung and head and neck. We saw activity in prostate.
We saw activity in triple-negative breast sarcoma, and of course,
small cell lung cancer. In the intent to treat patients, the response rate was
about 33%, and in small cell lung cancer, closer to
50%. And so of course,
the small cell lung cancer effort went forward into the ID-8
Lung-01 study for randomized dose optimization.
In 2023, Merck and Daiichi Sankyo entered an
agreement to co-develop this asset outside of Japan.
The FDA has accepted the BLA, and we have a PDUFA date in
October of this year
for the approval of this in patients with
refractory small cell.
Subsequently, a second B7-H3 antibody drug conjugate referenced by
an earlier speaker, YL201, it's the only one without a
name, was also launched into a large
phase one study. There were 312 patients
treated, 50 in dose escalation at a number of dose
levels that you see here from 0.8 to 3.0 milligrams per
kilogram once every three weeks. As well, 260
patients were treated in dose escalation.
These patients were separated by tumor type, small cell, NPC,
non-small cell, and esophageal squamous.
This phase one report, published in "Nature Medicine" in
2025, also showed that while there were various levels
of B7-H3 that were acceptable for patients to join the trial, there
was no correlation with patients' response rates as a result of
their B7-H3 expression. Roche licensed
YL201 outside of China in January of this year.
Medilink retains the rights in China, and it carries a breakthrough
designation at the FDA for small cell as well as
NPC in China.
Last but not least, the compound that we'll now refer to
affectionately as Risres
was also evaluated on a large phase one study,
Artemis001.
Likewise,
over 300 patients treated in this trial, once again with a
large dose escalation followed by dose expansion in
different tumor types who received either eight milligrams per kilogram or
10 milligrams per kilogram. The cohorts tested were non-small
cell lung cancer with or without AGA, Actionable
Genomic Alterations, as well as small cell lung cancer
and other advanced solid tumors, including notably
osteosarcoma.
And so as a result of this trial and the
publication of this phase one trial just recently in "Cancer Cell,"
there are many regulatory designations in the US,
in Europe, and in China for small cell lung cancer,
osteosarcoma, and other solid tumors,
which is the subject of today's abstract,
Artemis101, which combined
Risres with PD-L1 inhibitor
atezolizumab
in patients with pre-treated non-small cell lung cancer.
These patients all were known to be without AGA,
so they had some NGS report that showed no EGFR,
no ALK, et cetera, and they were previously treated with platinum
at a dose of eight milligrams per kilogram.
Notably to me, 75% or
three-quarters of patients had received immune therapy, but not the
whole
amount, and we would consider immune therapy to be a
first-line standard
in many parts of the world.
Also of note, as we talk about PD-L1 treatment in
this group of patients,
about 40% had TPS
less than 1%, and only 22% had
1% or higher. There was 40% of the patients,
remember only 40 patients total, that had
an unknown PD-L1. So this is a little hard for us to gauge
because we would expect 30% PD-L1 high,
30% in middle ranges of PD-L1, and 40%
PD-L1 low. Keep that in mind as we go.
Okay, so in this table, I've put the Artemis001
phase one trial non-small cell lung cancer without AGA
patients and their responses next to the
Artemis101 trial that combined
that Risres treatment with PD-L1.
So you can start to see the difference between monotherapy Risres
and Risres plus PD-L1 inhibitor. First, we
see an interesting increase in response rate from
33% up to nearly 50%. Interesting.
And even more interesting was the prolongation of duration of
response to over a year and the PFS that Dr.
Zong mentioned of 14%. So
unprecedented compared to four and
seven months in patients treated in that same scenario with
monotherapy. We start to see a little bit of a signal
in terms of the patients with higher levels of PD-L1 have a higher
response and longer duration,
87% without progression at a year.
But of course, these numbers are now getting really
small.As we compare Risres
plus aatebreliumab
to the monotherapy experiences in terms of
safety, we see that by and large this drug only
has-- or the most common side effects are hematologic toxicity
with very little rates of ILD with the possible
exception of IDXD with its DXd
payload here. And with the addition of PDL1, we see
really no change in the signal. So this appears to be
with adverse events that we would expect.
Oh, the one thing I guess I left off here is a little bit
more in the way of ILD. I think it was 10 of the 40 had had
a little bit of at least grade one, so something to
watch.
This is my favorite slide in their deck.
This is provocative to me that there are 14 patients
that are continuing on therapy over a year.
44% of patients still on therapy. And as I looked at this slide,
initially, I did wonder, who are these people?
How are they responding so well? We might say, "Well, what's
their PDL1 level? Are these perhaps the PDL1 naive
patients?" And so Hanso was nice enough to add this graph
on the side for me showing previous immune therapy in orange,
and so the naive patients in gray. And we can see that
the eight patients that were naive are sprinkled
throughout the long-term responders and the short-term responders.
So there's something special about this group, be it that they're a phase one
patient population that is provocative.
Taking a step back then,
the supposition is the addition of the
PDL1 inhibitor to the
B7H3s, the reason we see these prolonged
responses. And could that scientifically be the
hypothesis? Could ADCs reinvigorate anti-tumor
response? Of course, hypothetically, we see this quite a bit.
I did find a couple small cohorts showing that B7H3
expression can change with anticancer
treatments like chemotherapy and targeted therapy.
And in particular, the B7H3 can
increase
in both squamous and non-squamous lung cancer.
It was more common in patients with non-squamous lung cancer
after treatment with chemotherapy.
So after these patients have received chemo and maybe immunotherapy in the
frontline, it's possible that they could be
reinvigorated. However, there is an unclear relationship
between the target B7H3 and the target
PDL1 in these pretreated patients that have
received immune therapy. Here I found an experience
suggesting higher response rate in patients with
lower B7H3, rather than what you would expect it to be
the other way around for Risres and
adelemab to be synergistic in some
way. Just
as we stop back and think about this whole session today
and we think about what the next trial will be, Dr.
Zong mentioned that there is a phase three trial in second
line on small cell lung cancer versus docetaxel planned.
But of course, we've seen this movie before.
We did this in lung cancer with Trope-2 antibody drug conjugates.
The phase three trials are summarized at the top of this slide,
the Sasi Govatikan, as well as
Dato-DXd versus docetaxel. And in unselected
patients, neither antibody drug conjugate was better than
docetaxel. Both of those trials in unselected patients
were negative. And as we step back and look at that from the
rear view mirror, 56% any grade
stomatitis in a group of patients that didn't all benefit starts to
feel
like we should find the patients more selectively.
SAC-TMT decided to cut the cord early,
and they saw the success of Dato-DXd in
EGFR mutated patients and decided to do their pivotal trial
just in those EGFR mutated patients.
That was a positive trial reported in 2025.
Last slide then. Remember that we also have
seen the movie that reactivation of the immune
system is difficult when you're just adding a
drug with a different mechanism to PD-1 or
PDL1. So I've summarized three
negative trials here. Immunotherapy
plus
remucirumab, a VEGF-R2 antibody,
cabozantinib, a dirty TKI, as well as
siralimertib, an ATM
inhibitor. And in all of these cases, the early trials suggested that
there was something special going on.
Even this phase two Lung-Map trial suggested an
improvement in overall survival.
The Pragmatica trial, of course, will be reported in poster form, the final
analysis tomorrow at the poster session.
It was stopped early for futility because there was no improvement
over standard chemotherapy alone.
So these are all
lessons that we should incorporate.
If this drug combination does go forward in a phase three trial,
let's try to find the biomarker. Let's try to find the select group
of patients that will benefit from this
treatment
because this ARTEMIS-101 data is provocative but
immature.
Thanks for your attention.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. We have time for a couple of questions.
Hi. I had one comment and one question.
The comment is that the patient characteristics in this
population that was non-EGA was a little unusual.
If I remember correctly, almost 30% were never
smokers.
The rate of liver metastases was like 7%, rate
of brain metastases was 12%. In a patient with
recurrent non-small cell lung cancer, those numbers seem
not consistent with what we normally see.
So just wondered if Dr. Zong, you had any comment on that.
And then the second thing is, did you try to correlate
with-- was there any correlation between
efficacy on the frontline immunotherapy
and then what was seen with the combination?
That is, was there a correlation that patients who did well
on immunotherapy in the frontline also were the ones who did well
with the combination?
Thank you for your question.
And
in most of the patients, female patients in Asia,
they don't smoke. So the patients with
adenocarcinoma, they don't smoke.
So when we see the high incidence of the non-smokers
in trial. And as the
second question, and as the data have, we do
enroll some of the patients classified as the
primary resistance to immunotherapy.
As the data have, we enroll around five
patients. They were defined as the
primary resistance to
immunotherapy. And two
of the patients still in the treatment
under the combination therapy
for more than 11 months. And one
patient progressed after around six
months on the combination therapy, and two patients progressed
within two months. Thank you.
It would be nice to know if those patients that progressed quickly,
were they potentially among the group that
had more benefit in this experience?
Excuse me?
And then just a follow-up question, any of the patients with brain
metastases, were those active brain metastases and have you seen any
intracranial responses?
Sorry?
Brain metastases.
Like the brain metastases.
Brain and responses.
Whether the efficacy of the-
Yeah.
Any reduction, shrinkage.
There are several patients with brain
metastases. And as the data have,
around maybe 60%
of them, they remained stable or
tumor shrink
of the brain metastases.
Okay. Sounds good. Thank you.
All right. Thank you very much. This concludes this afternoon's
session. I'm going to thank you all the speakers and discussants for the
terrific presentations. And thank you all of you
for attending. Wish you a great rest of the day and
continue enjoying AACR in San Diego. Thank you.
Thank you.